lauren zema you spoke to the mistress of
ceremonies yes the vmas the one and only
dosia cat and she told me she is game
for anything
there are some big surprises at store
lauren how many costume changes are we
gonna get three outfits maybe something
like that you know like when you change
your outfit in your hair every five
minutes it feels like you're running
from the cops we're not
[Music]
the 25 year old won her first ever moon
person last year now she's hosting
performing and up for five awards
including artist of the year facing off
with the night's most nominated star
the biebs has seven knots and he's
singing on the vma stage for the first
time in six years expect justin to hit
the carpet with wife haley who is
presenting
lovebirds machine gun kelly and megan
fox will be there and she was spotted
reportedly wearing a ring on that finger
when she attended mgk's vmas rehearsal
but e.t has learned they are not engaged
he's also a brilliant creative genius as
a musician but tall blonde gorgeous
supermodel that's fair mgk is debuting a
new single with travis barker so we may
get a kourtney kardashian sighting but
two people we won't see performing lord
and nicki minaj
nikki pulled out of the show saying i'll
explain why another day now two hours
after that tweet news did break that her
husband kenneth petty pleaded guilty for
failing to register as a sex offender
stemming from a 1995 rape conviction he
faces up to 10 years in prison
as for why lord's not performing the 24
year old told fans she was planning a
big dance number with lots of people and
due to covet protocols it wasn't going
to be what i dreamed
[Music]
but we will still get shawn mendes and
camila cabello the couple will take the
stage separately performing their hits
live from brooklyn's barclays center
[Music]
so will mtv vma first-timer and
five-time nominee 18-year-old olivia
[Music]
rodrigo and get this olivia's a
contender for one of the night's biggest
honors artist of the year megan lee
stallion is also in that category and
her big hit with cardi b is up for video
of the year
something new this year the first ever
global icon award going to foo fighters
[Music]